madame plantes bonsoir mairesse de
montréal aussi aujourd'hui un plat pour
aider à stimuler un peu non seulement le
centre-ville mais la ville de montréal
qui qui paie un coût énorme comme les
autres grandes villes
33 millions d'années moi un seul exemple
de ce qui peut changer les choses dans
ce que j'allais investir mais entre
autres on va faire une très belle
campagne
toute la scène les restaurateurs on sait
qu'ils ont beaucoup souffert dans la
dernière année on a une scène de foodies
de grands chefs importante à montréal
on va également venir animer vous
centre-ville de l'année dernière les
crises passées savez bien fonctionné
mais là parce qu'on a eu plus de temps
et plus de moyens vont faire objet de
beaucoup plus gros et à peu près 500
artistes qui vont travailler sur les
différents aisée des demeures
installations centre-ville dont vous
créer de l'engouement on veut que les
gens aient envie de dire se promener
comme touristes comme des sites heures
puis aussi comme travailleur et comme
étudiant quelque part à la fin de l'été
la ville de new york avant d'ouvrir les
salles à l'intérieur on trouve rire les
terrasses parce que c'est des
discussions que j'avais de la santé
publique pour le il faut faire bon la
semaine prochaine le que les quinze
jours
bientôt on puisse ouvrir les terrasses
avec une distanciation
on est toujours en discussion avec la
santé publique je comprends très bien le
souhait des restaurateurs en trop
d'ouvrir des paires à ce qu'on sait déjà
pour aller manger à l'extérieur donc je
suis hyper sensible encore une fois faut
juste s'assurer que c'est sécuritaire
montréal est en zone rouge le docteur
doit nous parle quand même de cette
possibilité d'une troisième vague à
cause des variants donc oui je suis très
très ouvert mais on va y aller pas à pas
ça c'est certain
ok donc tuchel de mettre un temps la
tulle oui on le docteur douenne vous
êtes probablement dans deux semaines on
va avoir une meilleure voie on va se
croiser les doigts que ça se passe bien
parce que ça se passe bien
il faut le dire ça se passe oui ça se
passe bien louis nario à paris 1 58 oui
absolument
parce que mémorial et ont été très forts
très résilient il continue à le faire
d'ailleurs je les remercie tous et
toutes pour leurs sacrifices et je pense
qu'on veut passer au travers on est
tellement enthousiaste à lui dépassé un
été festif joyeux où est ce qu'on va
pouvoir être en plus plus grand groupe
si je peux dire finie on veut s'assurer
qu'on va pouvoir avoir des festivals à
voir au musée de l'animation de façon
différente
madame la mairesse la prolonge le
prolongement de la ligne bleue
ça devient ça devient presque
caricatural l'on reproche le
prolongement reposons reposant repos on
écoute
monsieur legault aujourd'hui il en a
parlé à rester là c'est pas long joe
effectivement il y avait pour la ligne
bleue le présent jeu d'expropriation
n'ont quoi les galeries d'anjou
donc tout est examiné mais on continue à
vouloir faire la ligne bleue oui à des
défis donc la ligue 2 va voir rejoindre
absolument plus vite avec nous qu'avec
n'importe qui dort plus vite avec nous
mais monsieur legault dit il y aura un
retard mais écoutez nous on travaille de
concert pour trouver des solutions parce
que moi aussi je veux que ça se passe
bien que ça soit rapide
ça coûte dans une raquette de prix donc
il ya des propositions qui ont été
faites québec là on attend de voir ce
qu'ils vont nous répondre mais
définitivement le travail se fait on
nous dit 18 mois de retard c'est ce que
c'est ce que vous comprenez c'est ce
qu'on comprend pourrait bien être avec
vous j'étais un peu surprise entendent
aujourd'hui parce qu'encore une fois
nous on a fait des propositions pour
accélérer oui à l'expropriation mais
aussi d'autres enjeux auxquels la ville
et la stm on a participé qu'on a donné
des recommandations ou du moins des
suggestions gouvernement du québec pour
a
j'ai vécu puis rentrer dans notre
calendrier donc vous avez appris au même
instant que nous qui allait avoir 18
mois de retard oui alors écoutez je vous
cacherais pas que nos équipes se parle
beaucoup au niveau du transport tant au
niveau de la vente du québec
ici au cabinet est ce qu'une information
qui est glissé mais dans tous les cas
moi je t'ai heureuse dans le centre du
québec réitère sa volonté de faire la
ligue 2 parce que moi je l'a vu elle est
nécessaire et pour moi le rien mais à
des bleus c'est complémentaire qu'il
faut aller de l'avant
bon mais est-ce que vous avez pas peur
par ailleurs que le rem de l'est s'il se
fait avant elle verra finalement dix
secondes on n'a peut-être pas autant
besoin de prolongement de la ligne bleue
mais je ne souhaite pas et je pense que
ça à desservir elle est mondiale et
maria l'aise parce que le rêve est somme
toute assez au sud alors que la ligne
bleue vient répondre à des besoins du
centre ans on pense à saint léonard
saint michel qui est un petit peu plus
loin mais sans france avec le r srb
pie-ix également dans le coin de saint
michel ya beaucoup de monde alors pour
moi c'est absolument nécessaire et en
même temps on se cachera pas aussi des
avantages avoir un métro aussi au niveau
de la rapidité et l'efficacité du coup
donc moi je souhaite vraiment qu'on
continue dans cette dans cette lignée
c'est le cas de le dire bon rapidement
leur m
surélevée sur rené lévesque est ce que
vous en êtes où dans votre réflexion est
ce que vous comprenez les arguments de
la caisse qu'ils ont peut pas faire
autrement ou au contraire vous êtes non
non il faut aller au fond des choses
pis il faut un souterrain mais ça sera
un super écoutez moi je les dis ce que
je lâche le voeu puis je le réitère les
pas question de jeter le bébé avec l'eau
du bain
ceci étant dit est important que la cdpq
vendant du québec répondre aux
interrogations et je pense que c'est un
message que j'ai beaucoup porté depuis
le début à dire il faut que les gens
comprennent ce qui se passe
quelles sont les raisons d'un scénario
plutôt qu'un autre parce que sinon ça
crée de la suspicion qui est pas
nécessaire alors moi je suis fou
lorraine
s'il est en surface il doit être
magnifique mais là aussi on a besoin
d'enfance que les groupes les citoyens
ont à dire
parce que on se laissera pas le rem 2.0
mais ne rien avoir dans son intégration
comme le rem 1.0 mais peut-il être
magnifique au dessus de la rue écoute et
qu'on tripes alors écoutez je me sens
mais on a vu des villes qui ont réussi
est ce que c'est de le mettre plus haut
pour s'assurer qu'on crée pas des
couloirs de vent on ne bloque pas la
luminosité le plein de possibilités mais
on doit être rassuré moi je pense que
c'est ça que la cdpq et le gouvernement
du québec doit entendre la population
veut être rassurée match revanche entre
d'un côté valérie plan de l'autre denis
coderre
première question toute simple un plat
je vous c'est sûr qu'ils se présentent
dans votre esprit
bella et taylor mais pour malte et il
m'a appelé pour me dire non il va pas
fait pour me le dire mais je pense que
là tout semble aller dans cette
direction là non
comment vous entrevoyez ce combat
politique c'est quelque chose quand même
un rematch en politique comme ça puis
pour une grande ville comme montréal
qu'on voit pas qui pourrait troisième
quatrième candidat donc ça reste comment
vous vous voyez sur ce combat politique
se présente
ben écoutez tout d'abord on va attendre
que le candidat en question est qui nous
fait un striptease depuis plusieurs mois
la finisse par le dire je pense que déjà
ça va aider parce qu'au final vous savez
vous lui demander de le dire oui parce
que je trouve qu'à ce moment cité des
gros enjeux mois la coved c'est moi qui
le gérait c'est moi qui est là depuis
début avec en laissant personne derrière
et beaucoup d'ouverture d'empathie et
l'hommage en ami d'avoir quelqu'un qui
se présente ce qui montre s'écoule à un
moment donné mais c'est la même chose
pour les autres candidats je pense que
le plus tôt est le mieux
parce qu'il ya des enjeux de société
importants qui
joueur débattent moi parce que je suis
très fier de ce qui s'est passé dans la
dernière mise très fier de ma gestion de
la crise et j'ai très hâte de proposer
les nouvelles plateformes
j'imagine mais ça risque d'être quand
même tout un conte bol ça risque d'être
on avait vu ça avec drapeaux à l'époque
tu essaieras il veut ravoir son poste at
il changé vous allez ça risque d'être
assez dur comme combat vous savez en
politique il ya tellement d'éléments qui
peuvent jouer dans enfin moi ce qui m'a
toujours interpellé moi je suis la même
personne ne songeait pas dans ce sens où
je suis je veux pas avoir à me définir à
ce moment si la campagne nous laissera
le temps mais je serai à la population
de décider ici effectivement ils ont
envie de travailler avec telle ou telle
personne mais moi je suis définitivement
déterminé à aller de l'avant je me
laisserais pas je me laisserai pas
intimider par quiconque se présente
devant moi là bas les plaintes on veut
se reparler de ça mais je retiens que
vous dites balises il a plongé les ja de
l'aude à merci à la prochaine